is this a little white wolf in here oh  my god I didn't even think about it but  ya know I just you know denim jackets  that's that's kind of what I meant you  know can you walk me through the moment  that you both found out together  convention center good boy  we're very excited for this show can you  guys walk me through the moment both of  you found out that Falcon is getting the  shield  how are you told how are you told I  think we both found out on set when  we're shooting shooting the singing I  think maybe you had a little separate  party about out there in the world is  while I found that on so it wasn't a  party we were watching football as  American men do on Sundays and that's  how I found out Chris pulled out the  scripted let me read the same no I was I  was I lost my cannolis I mean it was a  it was a it was a huge surprise it was a  huge surprise